c'est non mon salon maintenant écouter
le courroux du peuple français par la
voix l'organe magnifique à l'élan ghana
les leurs à l'organe du procureur
général de la république des proches
française
bon
[Musique]
françaises français belges belle aux non
monsieur le président comme sa chair
maîtresse
monsieur le chanteur stupéfiants avec
sow droz conjugales mesdames et
messieurs les jurés public chéri mon
amour
je suis extrêmement gênée monsieur le
président j'ai cru que c'était le
général massu qui comparaissaient
aujourd'hui j'ai été mal renseignés par
nos juges d'instruction donc je vais
parler de la guerre est bien amené c'est
bizarre quand le général massu viendra
nous parlerons d'amour celle son genre
[Rires]
ce qu'il nous faudrait c'est une bonne
guerre nombreux sont autour de nous les
gens qui lâche cette petite phrase en
soupirant mais l'instant d'après il
retourne vaquer à leurs petites vies
mesquine et il n'y pense plus or si nous
voulons vraiment la guerre il ne suffit
pas de l'appeler de nos voeux en levant
les yeux au ciel d'un air un puissant
pour qu'un sang impur abreuve de nouveau
nos sillons
il nous faut semer véhémentement l'idée
de la guerre faute de quoi cette drôle
de paix qui a envahi la france voici
près de 40 années maintenant finira par
nous en croûte est totalement les vraies
valeurs seront de plus en plus bafoués
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui seront de moins
en moins ce que c'était ma pauvre dame
et le respect se perdra de plus en plus
dans les usines du grand-père de souchon
comment faire alors pour être sûr
d'avoir la guerre à l'échelon planétaire
l' équilibre de la terreur est telle
qu'on ne peut guère espérer un conflit
mondial avant plusieurs semaines
à moins bien sûr d'un court circuit ou
d'une défaillance humaine
mais combien de chances avons nous de
voir un sous-officier bourg et se casser
la gueule juste sur le petit bouton
rouge de la force de frappe
non il ne faut pas rêver la troisième
guerre mondiale n'aura pas lieu ces
jours-ci
pourquoi un organiseur aurions nous pas
plutôt une guerre française une guerre
française dans laquelle les forces en
présence serait toute française
ce sera une guerre vraiment française
n'est rien rien que des morceaux de
français entier dedans
réf réfléchissons un instant prends ta
tête à demain mon cousin pour que l'idée
de guerre germe dans le coeur de l'homme
il suffit que l'homme entretiennent en
lui la haine de l'autre
en 1914 et jeune soldat français
croyaient dur comme fer que les
allemands avaient les pieds crochus
sentel purin et qu'il n'arrêtait de
boire de la bière que pour venir jusque
dans nos bras égorger nos fils et nos
compagnes
grâce à quoi à cette époque le jeune
français avait les cheveux courts et ne
fumait pas des saloperies que la morale
réprouve monsieur charmaine d'accord il
était mort mais les cheveux courts en
ces conditions pourquoi ne pas déclarer
une fois de plus la guerre à l'allemagne
direz vous c'est une très mauvaise
question je ne vous remercie même pas de
me l'avoir posée déclaré une guerre à
l'allemagne et même une guerre à
l'échelon européen d'où qu'elle vienne
se serait défier l'equilibre anti
apocalyptique déjà précaire édifiée par
les deux ogres détenteur de la force
total or ces deux titans se sont arrogés
de longue date l'exclusivité de la
solution finale du problème hommes par
la méthode dite du champignon définitif
et il ne nous la laisserons pas faire
non la seule guerre raisonnablement
envisageable c'est la guerre 100%
français et puisque la haine est le
moteur de la guerre apprenons à nous à y
rentrer nous mes frères
un certes il est plus facile de haïr les
arabes ou les anglais dont les moeurs
incroyablement primitive ont de quoi
nous révulse et est ce que je mange du
gigot à la menthe en me tournant vers la
mecque moi non je suis normal
je mange des cuisses de grenouilles en
me tournant vers guide arbore ainsi pour
bien nous haïr entre français nous
devons tenter d'oublier tout ce qui nous
unit et mettre l'accent sur ce qui nous
sépare chaque région de ce pays à six
rites et coutumes qui ne sont pas les
mêmes que ceux de la région d'à côté
apprenons à les connaître
apprenons à les détester c'est à ce prix
que nous aurons la guerre civile franco
française ultime recours pour nous
sortir de la crise alors voyons région
par région les béarnais les béarnais
sont ils des gens comme nous je dis non
j'ai sous les yeux un pot de sauce
béarnaise voulez vous savoir ce qu'ils
mettent dans la sauce berne elle les
béarnais c'est une autre huile de soja
63% farine de maïs 0 9%
estragon cerfeuil 1 9% excipients 1 312
0 2% à consommer de préférence avant le
6 mars 1984 pas d'utilisation prolongée
sans avis médical
l'huile de soja 63%
d'où vient tout ce soja mais de chine
bien sûr de là à prétendre que les
béarnais ont signé un pacte secret avec
la chine rouge
il n'y a qu'un pas allons-nous hésité à
le franchir allègrement n'ont d'autre
part de poa fois et deux fois à pau on
ne rend compte que des dégénérés
alcoolique détruit jusqu'à l'os par les
abus du jambon de bayonne que ces
gens-là trempe dans en tranches épaisses
dans leur grand bol plein d'alcool de
pruneaux d'agen bien sûr
ainsi ceux de pau ont des maladies de
foie et ce deux fois on est mal et du
pot c'est dégueulasse sus mais pr marc
obernai les bourguignons les
bourguignons sont ils des gens comme
nous je dis non
d'abord dans la fondue bourguignonne ils
mettent de la sauce béarnaise ce sont
donc des collabos n'ayons pas peur des
mots
d'autre part les bourguignons ont ils
jamais été capable de produire quoi que
ce soit de bon à partir du sol de la
bourgogne
certains noms me disais justement
l'autre jour un ami vigneron près de
bordeaux certes quelques régions de
bourgogne dont une humble piquette que
les un bref c'est à dijon que les autres
pistes de bonne mère mais peut-on
appeler ça du vin monsieur pourtant
pelli peut-on appeler ça du vin eh bien
je dis non quant aux dijonnais eux mêmes
leurs moeurs dissolues sont une insulte
permanente à la mémoire de louis 11 qui
fut à la fois le père de la
réunification de la bourgogne qui
commença par le traité d'art à 114 182
et l'amant de charles martel qui
commença par le traité de kaunas en 1983
la nuit les moeurs des dijonnaises sont
tellement dissolue qu'on entend plus les
couinements de leur chat il les couvre
de leurs hurlements d'extase un pur qui
monte cette année et lugubre vers la
lune quand la nuit tombe et que l'amour
tarde de dijon
m
enfin les bourguignons ont contribué à
la ruine de notre marine marchande en
revendant nos plus beaux bateaux de
commerce aux arabes
il n'y a qu'un seul ex paquebot de
france alors que c'est par douzaines
cocon aujourd'hui les ex cargo de
bourgogne juste mais pr mort burgondes
les bordelais sont ils des gens comme
nous je dis non
certains habitants du bordelais boivent
du vin de bourgogne ce sont des collabos
n'ayant toujours pas peur des mots les
bordelais sont très laid au reste dans
bordelais il y allait de même que dans
pinochet il ya au chai comment se
fait-il que les bordelais soit s'il est
alors que leurs femmes sans gironde
c'est un grand mystère c'est un grand
mystère est une nouvelle occasion de
nous esbaudir devant l'impénétrabilité
des dessins du seigneur les bordelaises
ne sont pas aussi impénétrables que les
dessins du seigneur c'est une raison de
plus pour déclarer la guerre à ces gens
d'ailleurs carte russie du cfer nique et
mam et l'usg et ram est tué violé sont
les deux mamelles de la guerre mais
seigneur que les bordelais sont laids
avez vous vu à quoi ressemble duc de
bordeaux sus mais pr mort aux bordelais
mesdames et messieurs les jurés le temps
qui m'est imparti touche à sa femme mais
dans un prochain réquisitoire françaises
français belges belle du chercheur ont
de bonnes raisons d'attaquer la
seine-et-marne
[Applaudissements]
cqfd
[Musique]
fait peu mon nom